like are you following this bagel boss
guy on the internet no there's a guy who
went into a bagel boss and he's 4 foot
11 and he's very angry with women
because he's having trouble getting late
I guess so he exploded and bagel boss
and it went viral we should be dead
that's okay well I know yesterday for
like a couple of hours the bagel boss
guy was hanging out in the greenroom
really yeah I got a call from his
manager over the weekend he has a
manager I think he's already doing
celebrity boxing Oh is he
oh good my watch that
that's the biggest thing that's ever
happened is surely what are you crazy
you won't fight that guy you could beat
him up I would of course I can but why
would I fight him because it'll be great
for the show and we'll bring you a lot
of attention you're telling me he's not
only in that fight buddy I'm tiny he's
shorter than me I know he's 411 yeah you
I'm five six I just had heard you were
taking pictures with him - he has to
take a picture with you yeah you gotta
fight him well now if you're telling me
you want this done that's a different
story problem you want to fight I want I
want the fight I think we could have a
great time with the build-up you got to
do this it's gonna be so funny ma'amed
says he's putting $100 on the bagel boss
gotta stick around yeah we're back get
in here it'll be great batting what a
mother for my money's on you if you
can't eat him I'm never coming back here
if I don't oh my god will you train will
you like train did you see the size of
that bagel boss guy guys angry dude and
he is built he's small I mean you're not
you did you see him I saw him
he's piney by the way there are multiple
people back there saying that they would
put money on really really yeah I'm a
man I'm a cool you don't think surely
could be tough a small guy and he's got
an insane anger that I don't think
Shirley's gonna be able to get past she
was mine
Shirley's gonna knock them down and just
start beating them his arms are big
yeah okay but if you can't reach me with
short [ __ ] arms that are wide what
does it matter I can't even believe that
you're Bowie math PS surely is an angry
guy thank you
I like this guy Shirley's been doing
stand-up he's not getting anywhere he's
someone has drawn attention thank you
take a look at Julie's life we got a
whole bunch of kids Chili's plenty anger
I don't I don't [ __ ] scream at
strangers everywhere I go but there's
anger there how could you think bagel
boss guy could beat up Julie I'll go
with his arms why dude you might see he
works at did you see him face to face
Gary did you meet him yesterday it's not
a cut against you no but I'm asking the
question just like you but you don't
have much endurance because you've been
smoking a ton of weed well that's the
things you weed and save so it's gonna
have to end early that's your only hope
man goes past the first round I'm fine I
think I think we have to have bagel boss
guy up here and work out the details
right that's good I want to make sure
that I got concrete deal with this guy
yes right right and I'm getting
something before oh yeah no no we're
gonna talk yeah yeah man pop out that
checkbook brother you're Don King's all
upset he missed that
you